So doctors are absolutely furious with Donald
Trump for spreading the completely bogus conspiracy
theory that doctors are inflating the number
of Corona virus deaths for profit and that
that's why our numbers are so bad.
I'm going to explain this to you and explain
the genesis of this.
Donald Trump has said that we only have high
case numbers because we test so much.
And now he's saying that we only have such
high deaths despite claiming they're low because
doctors make money by lying about the cause
of death.
Take a look at this clip and then we're going
to discuss it.
This is from one of Trump's hair brained Saturday
Korona rallies.
This one in Waukesha, Wisconsin.
Take a look.
You know, some countries, they report differently
if somebody's sick with a heart problem and
they die of covered.
They say they died of a heart problem.
If somebody is terminally ill with cancer
and they have covered, we report them and,
you know, doctors get more money and hospitals
get more money.
Think of this incentive.
So some countries do it differently.
If somebody is very sick with a bad heart,
they die of Colvert.
They don't get reported covered.
So then you wonder, gee, I wonder why the
cases are so low.
This country and their reporting systems are
really not doing it right.
If somebody has a really bad heart and they're
close to death, even if they're not, but they
have a very bad heart and they get covered,
they put it down to covered.
Other countries put it down to a heart.
So we have to be a look at it things because,
you know, they have things.
They have things a little bit backwards.
They have things a little bit back.
Joe Biden is very seriously.
If you hear Donald Trump say that and you
like it and you believe it and you clap.
How can you be trusted to have any job?
I mean, really short of some completely menial
task with no contact with other people.
How can you have a job that involves interacting
with people in any way?
Teaching kids, being an accountant?
I mean, just about any job.
How could you be trusted to do anything if
you believe when Trump says cause of death
is being forged for doctors to profit?
There are 60 million of these people.
My friends, it is a living nightmare in the
United States.
But understand that Donald Trump has become
your crazy uncle, spreading fake news on Facebook.
This specific conspiracy theory is one that
I don't know if it started on Facebook, but
it was popular on Facebook for a while.
It's been around since early in the pandemic.
Stuff like if a doctor says you have covered,
they get an extra seventeen thousand dollars
if you die of it.
Now, I do actually want to explain where this
comes from, where it started so that you're
equipped to deal with it.
As many of you know, hospitals are paid based
on diagnosis and treatment.
What do they diagnose and what do they treat?
What do they do to a patient?
Medicare.
So, again, we're talking about only people
of Medicare age.
Medicare pays hospitals, reimburses hospitals
20 percent more for coronavirus patients relative
to my guess, as a non coronavirus, sort of
like flu admission because people of Medicare
age on average require more treatment and
corona virus on average has certain protocols
that costs more money.
Right.
So.
So you would it makes sense that if on average,
corona virus is multiple times more deadly
than the flu and on average, older folks are
more likely to have a serious case than younger
folks.
It would make sense that when Medicare age
people are admitted to a hospital for coronavirus,
there's going to be more treatment provided.
And that costs more money in the system that
we have.
That would lead to a higher reimbursement.
Now, the conspiracy.
First of all, there is no evidence that hospitals
are fraudulently saying people have coronavirus
when they don't.
In order to pad their revenue, that would
be extremely serious insurance fraud.
But most importantly, even look at actually
think about it, a patient dying has no impact
on revenue.
There is no reason to lie because Trump is
talking about cause of death.
There is no reason to lie about cause of death.
And, of course, it would be hugely immoral.
And doctors groups are furious that Donald
Trump is suggesting that Rob Davidson is an
emergency room doctor who's part of the committee
to protect Medicare.
He said, quote, As a doctor, this is such
an insult.
We report deaths, how they occur.
If you did your damn job, we wouldn't be reporting
so many covered 19 deaths, about one hundred
and thirty thousand fewer, according to a
Columbia University study.
This is a very common thing on the right.
Everything's fake.
It's a smoke screen.
Climate change is fake.
COVA deaths are fake.
And then when they explain why it's money,
someone is lying for money, which is what
they would do.
This is the incredible projection that is
here.
When they don't want to accept the scientific
reality, they assume someone must be lying
in order to make money for themselves.
And it's a big peek behind the curtain for
Trump.
He must think everyone on Earth must be as
terrible a person as he is.
And so if he would lie for personal gain.
The doctors must also be lying for personal
gain.
And by the way, I don't even know if we need
to do this.
The virus as a way to make hospitals money.
Hospitals are getting crushed during coronavirus.
Hospitals make money with necessary but not
urgent surgeries, hip replacements, knee scopes,
so on and so forth.
Those are all down dramatically during the
pandemic.
So the idea that the virus is a hoax generated
to make money for the medical industry is
absurd, because when you look at the Q2 GDP
decline, the leading declining industry was
the health care industry.
This has been terrible for the medical field.
Health care has been decimated by the virus.
E.R. visits are down, outpatient visits down,
surgeries down short and long term care prevented
from prohibited from admitting people for
four months during this huge increase in PPE
costs for the hospitals, even though they
have fewer patients.
It's been bad.
It doesn't make any sense.
We must end this insanity.
Barack Obama's trying to help end it.
And I want to talk about that a little bit.